islip new york
rich with history and community spirit
but a crown jewel of this seaside
village the seascape inn is on the verge
of collapse
the owners are a mother named irene and
a son named peter
you can't put him in a dining room to
shut the [ __ ] up tell him to get out of
here it's a big deal close the [ __ ]
toss if you don't like him
the seascape has been around since 1962.
we've been declared the oldest
restaurant in the town of iceland
in the glory days at the seascape my
father he was here when they were doing
300 covers on a saturday night and the
place was alive and everybody was
smiling
making money there was love everywhere
and you could feel it when you walked
into the seascape
i started torque here at the seascape in
1967.
it was buzzing
you wouldn't believe
the amount of customers we had on
saturday night they'd actually stand
online outside the door
the restaurant it's in a dumpster now
[Music]
i don't even like to tell people i work
here anymore
there's a lot of contributing factors of
why you know people don't come back
we've had complaints about that sewage
smell
there was a stink in this place so bad
and i can't believe anybody came in at
all
maybe the reason why the restaurant has
gone down in the last past two years
because chef doug is not listening to a
word
i say it doesn't make a difference if i
wanted to serve the now that's what i
want to serve them
i've been doing this 38 years
i went to the culinary institute of
america i worked in successful
restaurants world renown
i like having the command in the kitchen
anybody's got a problem with it they can
come to me i'm going to say my piece
wherever i go to whoever i meet doesn't
matter their status i really don't care
don't serve it in that that's all you
got to do it's that simple
doug's loud and obnoxious you want a
rock let's rock
he's crazy
my father he was a hands-on in the
kitchen i was always the guy that was
out front and two years ago my father
passed away
after he passed away he did hurt us
the rug is being pulled out from um to
me and i got to do something about it i
need 800 to a million dollars to save
the seascape
i don't want my doors to close but what
am i doing wrong chef ramsay is my last
hope because if chef ramsay can't help
me it's done
i'm not wasting more time
[Music]
this building's 105 years old and when
this restaurant first opened 40 years
ago is the hot spot in town now it's at
the bottom i'm starting to understand
why
what is that pile of [ __ ] there
god
[Music]
good morning good morning how are you
how are you doing my first name sorry
peter peter gordon good to see you his
height threw me off didn't realize how
tall he was does make you a little bit
more intimidating
mom this is gordon ramsay nice to see
you it's a pleasure to meet you also i
was very impressed with him very
handsome very tall
blonde good-looking actually if it was
like 20 years ago i would have said you
know what we connect
this is uh the veteran waitress maryland
wow who's been here since the the
beginning
and when you say beginning how long have
you been here well i really started in
1967 67 right i left i was born then
maybe chef ramsay's gonna tell me i just
wouldn't be here i'm too old and i'd
respect him if he said that i'll be out
the door and this is chef dough dough
how are you
nice mini skirt there what is that an
apron yeah what
oh this is oh okay yeah nice that's my
wiping rack how's your wiping rack
gordon ramsay coming here to me
it's a slap in the face
now let's get in the dining room let's
go let's have a blast all right
okay you run the place
and your mum assists you yes yes
describe seascape for me it's a titanic
it was a luxury liner
and it's sinking i see it as a very
poorly run restaurant that's the last
time she gave me a compliment because
you just don't listen and that's why
compliments are very hard to come by
god right now
i'm hungry i want to taste the food and
let's meet after shall we absolutely is
there anything else that i need to know
before i start eating the border health
came here and believe me they gave us
95. so the place is clean right where
should i go for uh
thank you you're so welcome i was
excited
uh little butterflies in the stomach i'm
gonna be insulted by the best chef in
the world
there's some really bad smell in here
sewage
[Music]
i can't believe people come in here
okay well i'll start off with the um
crab cakes please okay i like the idea
of the pesto lobster ravioli i'll go for
the atlantic salmon uh blackened please
call me a pig okay i'm i'm hungry
yeah well
at least she's honest
place stinks
i feel like this place don't nightmare
uh who's this
that's chef ramsay okay no problem uh
one order of crab cakes
[Music]
[Applause]
this place is falling apart
let's hope the food's good oh hey can we
crab cakes
[Music]
parsley everywhere
crab cake just falls apart
but like the decor you touch it just
disintegrates they're not fresh
they've got it wrong on the menu it's
not a crab cake
it's a crap cake
because i feel if i eat anymore i'll be
crapping for the next 105 years
are they frozen i don't think so would
you answer them for me sure it tastes
frozen okay thank you
doug you make the crab cakes here right
yes are they frozen
i freeze them yeah
he says they taste like they're frozen
that's all
really yeah
they are frozen
damn
more parsley
soggy
strange taste inside they're definitely
not fresh uh on that cajun salmon you
want you still want the uh sauteed
spinach and a pesto or
[Music]
what is that that is pesto
is it good well it's just all separated
and i have no idea it looks like an oil
slick yeah and it's never on the side
it's usually served on the fish when i
serve in the sam and he did have
something to say about the pesto sauce
it was
painted
so to speak
and the salmon is just solid inside and
dry and
you can't expect customers to
come and pay for that [ __ ]
you definitely have to try my homemade
greek cookies and i basically you're
gonna say you never had a better one oh
chef ramsey he's a lot like me
i love him when you eat that cookie you
lift it up and you bite
[Music]
[ __ ] me you got water i suppose you guys
are still alive
he just choked on your mother's cookie
i mean i don't have an answer i don't
before gordon passes on his comments to
the chef and the owners he decides to
observe a dinner service to get a more
complete picture of the problems in the
restaurant
the new england clam chowder smells
fishy
[Music]
it's a little bit too pinky for me
yeah it's a little cold
i'm telling you truth it's cold it is
cold this is so sad so [ __ ] upset
with customers complaining in the
restaurant gordon looks to the owner to
solve the problems sir like i said
if you think i scam do me a favor do
what you gotta do but i would have
there's no more there's one thing before
you make the phone call not in front of
customers getting here
now my god
oh my
after being disappointed with the front
of the house it was time to check out
the engine room of the restaurant the
kitchen
doug
he said this is cold and feel the plate
it is cold
no it's not cold it's not
hey guys these plates are stone cold
if the plate was cold would you take it
out diane yeah you would they put it up
i take it [ __ ] me
no it's all right
i don't worry about it
what's your uh fascination with the
parsley on the plate
i i just happened to wait like the
parsley loves to be honest with you
it stinks it's dried parsley it's a sign
of a dated russian sprinkle it on your
wife but not on the [ __ ] flames yes
he may not like the way i cook he
doesn't like the way i cook that's his
opinion
oops oh god
[Music]
why aren't they cleaning it all right i
got a few pieces
this is extraordinary
stop there come here how [ __ ] can you
walk past that ship pay them to work in
it yeah
i mean he just spilt a buck a bucket of
[ __ ] tomato sauce
why can't you say something to him
about cleaning up his mess
[Music]
chef doug has not listened to a word i
sang but sometimes i'm not in the mood
what is going on
oh no he's got a mop
peter
peter one second did you hear what i
said marriage i didn't ask you to go mop
up their [ __ ]
used to doing it yeah oh god that's not
the right answer but what a sad [ __ ]
oh can i clean it now
while peter cleans up the mess on the
floor
when was the last time this place was
cleaned
gordon realizes that this is part of a
bigger problem
[Music]
[Music]
before the staff comes in to prepare for
lunch gordon arrives early to do a
thorough investigation of the kitchen
oh god
what is that
twice baked potato thank [ __ ] i missed
that one twice
oh wow
so dirty
god when was that cleaned
oh god
what is that
this is ten thousand times worse than i
thought it would be
looks like lather
of [ __ ]
and crap
kitchen health hazard
bingo
my fresh
lobster ravioli
soggy
strange taste inside
fresh
my [ __ ]
i've eaten this [ __ ]
the general hygiene
in refrigeration
oh [ __ ] help
so that's the pesto
i had for lunch
[Music]
just look at the colors in there
look at that
it's moldy
it's now lunchtime the chefs are
preparing customers are getting ready to
eat but gordon steps in please have a
quick word we're both here two seconds
oh
when was last time you went in the
kitchen and had a
little look round once every tuesday or
so we'll go in the walls scrub them down
god
when was that cleaned
irene you mentioned earlier about how
clean right this place was the border
health came here and believe me that
gave us 95 so the place is clean
that's 95 out of 100 right i really
don't think you've got any idea
can i just take you in there sure come
on let's go yeah
is that an order yeah you just stop
charles stop what you're doing
are you aware how filthy your kitchen is
yes ma'am how dare you cook me a lunch
out of this kitchen known for well how
filthy your kitchen is
so you don't even walk behind the line
look at him
everything come here
peter get your [ __ ] head under there
dog look under there why have we got
product in there why are you using it
why is it not condemned
to have another chef in my face about my
kitchen i'm pissed off probably
even a croutons gone mouldy oh my god
would you eat that
let's go in the walk-in fridge
i'm amazed how i'm amazed how you're so
cool and chilled at this you know that
dog food in the fridge that's the fish
bag it's what
god
actually that's that was for me actually
that's for you yeah don't eat it don't
[ __ ] eat it i already have you've
eaten it smell that then
it smells sour probably sour outside are
you [ __ ] mad
sour on the outside oh come on it's pork
the pork was mine that's my that's my
personal meals oh [ __ ] how
i didn't expect this kind of a mess that
i've seen i'm very upset i mean that's
the only way to put it very disappointed
very upset what's this
that's a chicken uh valdistano does that
look half cooked started to be cooked
thank you
i'm i'm just not a throwaway person that
was cooked on friday and i had to
re-cook it saturday that's what you got
to do you kill
whatever customers we've got left
what have you got to say about it as
someone that owns the place
when it comes to the freshness of the
food that really falls on just the chef
alone can we get out of here it's his
name it's fully his fault get me the
bowl of pesto please charles
what was my main course in there
yesterday you had a cajun salmon that's
right what's the sauce
sauce was a pesto sauce bring it over
please
you're right i didn't see it
you didn't see that i didn't see that
you got glasses on the man the pesto
sauce that was not forgivable i'm
humiliated about that believe me
positively
positively
now this is not a time hey to laugh and
take the [ __ ] piss out of me i've
eaten this [ __ ]
what's going on peter
i'm surprised that gordon didn't make
him eat it
and this is scrubbed every tuesday oh
[ __ ] every [ __ ] week you've got the
nerve to tell me that you clean the
walls every [ __ ] tuesday
[ __ ] off with you touch the wall you
dirty pig this is disgusting
i'm closing it down how many is booked
about 20. 20. forget it
get the place steam clean from [ __ ]
head to tail i don't care but we're not
cooking a [ __ ] cookie out of here
marilyn marilyn yes sir nothing's coming
out of this kitchen okay fine when chef
ramsay shut down the restaurant it was
shocking of course and his face was all
red chef ramsay he was really upset okay
should i tell the customers outside to
leave
please
switch it off we're going down now
okay thank you for coming but the chef
ramsay actually he wants to open up
tomorrow all my years will never shut up
a kitchen and tell the customers to go
home never and that's that's an
embarrassment
not here anyway
why don't you clean when you're quiet i
stay busy all day from 11 o'clock when i
walk in the door until 5 30 6 when we
get tables dude every day
doing preparation every day by myself
gordon ramsay he can go off on somebody
for absolutely no reason it's impossible
to clean everything and he just doesn't
get it what'd you find so funny charlie
what'd you find what what's funny for
you
what do you want me to do stand here and
start trying something
what do you want me to do i don't know
where you were
kiss your ass and say i think you do a
great job and clean on tuesday nights
when you [ __ ] sat on your crack doing
[ __ ] all right are you gonna do anything
or you're gonna stand and stare at me
[Music]
is that your weakness you don't know how
to run staff you know this is what they
keep telling you and that's why i keep
telling you all this time
tell them to shut the [ __ ] up tell him
to get out of here close the [ __ ]
doors if you don't like him take charge
this is what he's looking for a man
and that's what i'm looking for you to
become
where's your fire this is your mom
where's your fight you are running a
business
you're lucky i'm not standing here with
a [ __ ] rit on your ass about being
food poisoned
i've never done that before close down
the restaurant but that was a [ __ ]
nightmare seascape open
close the [ __ ] place
after spending 24 hours cleaning
what a difference
you've got your kitchen back to where it
should be yeah it's now day four and if
there's any hope of relaunching the
restaurant gordon has to get through to
the chefs all right doug
we'll do a quick special for tonight yes
we're gonna do a pan
seared space so with some crushed
potatoes it's time for this seafood
restaurant to put fresh fish back on the
menu tomatoes basil just bang just makes
it a little bit more vibrant yeah i've
been doing this for 38 years i'm not
happy at all i think he needs to back
off class is beautiful
let's come down to the point where i
really don't listen anymore let him do
what he wants
fresh and fragrant okay can we take it
through i want peter yeah and i mean to
taste it yes
[Music]
irene i want you to taste that first i
want you to say it as well so it's a
fresh vibrant tomato sauce
it's very good it's awesome
you don't want to taste it no i'm good
no i'm good thank you i didn't try the
fish that gordon had made
because i i basically know what striped
bears taste like if you are a chef of 38
years experience just tell me why you
didn't want to taste that
i know it's right best tastes like i'm
familiar with this doug one more chance
you sure you don't want to taste that
positive
he didn't even have the courtesy of
trying god that's the first time a guy's
never tasted my
food now i'm seriously insulted
now that gordon has shown them how to
make the special it's time to see doug
and charlie in action
okay good off we go
i don't expect my cooking to be like his
i don't expect fight baths to be like
kids at this point i don't really want
to be here
that's burnt charlie what are you doing
what the [ __ ] is this
could he not cook a piece of fish
chef ramsey i didn't want to listen to
what he had to say again the fish is
cooked to [ __ ] there's [ __ ] and piss all
over the place oh yeah whatever
i don't know how both of you can even
attempt to call yourself chefs you know
that [ __ ] your four-star chef [ __ ]
i'm
[ __ ] believable i am so pissed off a
sous-chef that can't cook fish head chef
that's just moping around doesn't care
this is a joke
i've seen
all i need to see
you're head chef
he's lazy dirty and he shouldn't be
anywhere near a kitchen
he's destroying your business quicker
than you can [ __ ] realize
couldn't even be bothered to taste what
i'd cooked in 21 years of cooking that
is a first for me
you asked me to come here to work and
fix your [ __ ] business
i can't do it
with those two schmucks in there
you have got to make the biggest
decision you've ever made
since your father passed away
whether you continue to work with the
dead wood that have drifted into your
business
or whether you wake up
get a grip
and be the boss
the one thing that i need you to carry
out for me
i want you to go in the kitchen and ask
doug
and charles to take off
[Music]
doug got too comfortable in being lazy
there's no excuse for that
decision's yours
and i realized at that moment that
something had to be done
do you agree with me 100
irene how does that sound to you that's
what is horrible
fire them fire them in a spot that's
what i want to hear that's what he wants
to hear they're not good enough for this
place
[Music]
guys both off tomorrow
are we done here together
you sure
yes
i kind of expected it from the way that
we work tonight
so
am i a little uh upset about it i'm a
little bit upset
right here
right now i'm humiliated it's just
freaking hard it's hard
[Music]
it's now day five and the seascape is
still closed before gordon can solve the
chef crisis he has to light a fire under
peter
so this exercise is a way that you let
go release and let go yes you need that
right now release the tension
okay good get in the [ __ ] ring
are you ready turn around stand on here
like that aren't there one two
back
when you release that third one one two
boom back you shout and scream one two
ah come on you suck your [ __ ] get good
good i'm not hearing anything inside you
you're still holding it in let's go now
i can feel it
now i can see your boss come on again
i don't know what's happened but the
last three or four punches have been
stronger and stronger because i realized
how much of an ass i was hey what wife
you've been honest with me
uh
i kind of lied to you
i knew my kitchen was dirty
i did
what i've been doing my whole life
keeping the peace
and keeping myself down
you've got no reason to keep yourself
down peter my fault
gave me a compliment
told me i sucked
never could do nothing with my life he
was a great worker yeah but didn't give
a [ __ ] about his own son who cared about
him
i'd let him destroy me
he died before i could prove him wrong
you're doing that now
prove him [ __ ] wrong you're right
let's go
i blamed my father for my failures and
it was myself can't blame him no more
come on
how do we get this gym in the restaurant
while gordon was having a breakthrough
with peter his design team was
remodeling the restaurant
hello hello welcome come in come in come
in please irene come through oh my god
oh my god the color irene i love it i
love it definitely
[Music]
the red definitely does it look how warm
it is
new wood
it's absolutely gorgeous we definitely
needed the change and thank god
chef ramsay you did it all you brought
exactly the whole seascapes back even
the bar stools
[Music]
it gives it back the old seascape charm
why'd you say it full of people it is
gorgeous marilyn how do you feel my
darling because this must go back in
time for you i can't believe the change
can you
i'm overwhelmed i really am look at your
pictures miss
and to see my picture up on the wall
makes me feel really good that i am
maybe part of the history of this
restaurant i might even cry
it looks almost like the old seascape it
has been brought back to life definitely
i think it's wonderful i really do
[Music]
uh peter and ladies tonight is the most
important night in the history of
seascape
tonight we're relaunching
i am so thrilled i am so thankful i
never expected this
never
i'm still dreaming
i'm still dreaming with the staff
reinvigorated by the new decor the focus
now goes to the kitchen how are you
doing scott peter
after scouring the local community
gordon has found a new head chef to
replace doug got the ball by the horns
and [ __ ] you know go for it yes and
with only hours until relaunch it's
straight to work preparing the new menu
okay the smart and basil sauce the idea
behind this is just giving it a little
bit of uh vibrance nice clean fresh
flavor here yeah a little bit of basil
don't rush
find your feet yeah
i'm fine no i can see if you're nervous
okay good
we've involved some of the old classics
from seascape and put a modern
interpretation on them okay let's go
through together fresh homemade crab
cake fresh pesto salmon clams casino
fried calamari surf and turf
okay any questions
where's the fork
all around it's a great menu god must
have sent them
i love this stuff
with the new menu and decor all in order
the next step was to turn peter into a
proper mater d peter jean-baptiste
jean-baptiste runs at my restaurant in
new york okay his parents are from leon
and he grew up in restaurants okay and i
want him to spend some quality time now
in just sort of grooming you you're now
getting polished
uh first thing is how do you feel about
wearing jackets
too stiff maybe we can get one for
tonight don't you think i'm not the most
fashion savvy guy around um show me how
you walk around tables your nice flowing
motion
[Music]
was everything right so far this is you
walking
yes every time i see you it's like
running around like a [ __ ] baby
rhinoceros trying to have a [ __ ]
[Music]
can you just walk nice and slowly put
your shoulders back
nice and slow
there you go
there look
nice and again
lovely
actually it's gonna be two seven tops
over here
i gotta prove myself to everybody the
town of islip
uh to myself to my employees to my
mother to my father
now i just want 30 seconds with you
it's a fight to re-establish this place
oh yeah i understand that my dad passed
away two years ago
so there's no way i can talk to my
father
so i feel it's the close second
how are you feeling nervous
last chance
[Music]
okay new decor new menu new chef
and now i hope a new boss speaking for
the first time in this guy's life he's
got to step up to the mark come out with
a shadow of his
father and prove to his mother and
himself he's more capable of running
this business let me have the phone no
no the phone stays here because he
doesn't make it tonight he's gonna
[ __ ] sink
tonight is the beginning of the new
seascape why before it is sweating
i'm looking at the bigger picture i
gotta prove to my father but i can't
control what's going on completely new
menu i'll have the uh clams casino i'm
having the seared stripes
thank you very much
the wait staff is revitalized by the
influx of customers and the new attitude
of the seascape and table five fire
please first ten tables are here um
atmosphere is electric it smells like a
proper restaurant peter now has to get a
grip understand what's going on and host
the room we're looking at probably about
a 20-minute wait a hundred customers
were coming at us and coming at us hard
we were swamped how are we gonna see
those people and how long long time
they're gonna wait
now you start to be messy trust me no
it's messy
so far
i think it's not going that well to be
honest all right peter this is where we
need to step up again now i'm going to
go talk to him we've got to step up big
time let's go
[Music]
with the restaurant packed the new chef
and the veteran waitresses are about to
be put to the test everybody keeps
taking food out of here this one is not
me okay then it must be diane
okay
these girls aren't used to being [ __ ]
busy
come on
okay this is where it's really critical
that a manager starts running his bloody
dining room because peter's restaurant
is now in the ship orders are getting
backed up the service is starting to
become slow kitchen's falling behind
peter you've got to start cracking the
whip the kitchen is so backed up i'm so
sorry it's coming babe it's coming
would go so perfect and it's just not
the food's just not coming out i've been
waiting for the uh entrees it's like six
o'clock 6 30.
what's the matter my two kids still
haven't eaten
and what were they getting what were
they getting muscles
muscles are an appetizer okay
i'll show
oh sky what table three did not get
their appetizers
i mean they only been here since
freaking 6 30. that's gonna that goes on
the back of the line that you got to
wait hold on let's get one thing done in
a time quieted a long time ago and no no
when we fired it it still goes on the
back of the line
peter the wait staff here they're too
set in their ways oh scott when i
ordered the french on you automatically
make them for me right no one telling
them what they can and can't do they're
just coming in they're taking what they
want they're just grabbing food is that
yours are mine diane this this is mine
it's very frustrating
i can't communicate when this is too
stupid making sure the front of the
house is in sync with the kitchen is
peter's responsibility
and irene is losing her patience because
he's not stepping up and taking control
please somebody pick up this food my
apologies i'm sorry
mom what are your wines what are you
doing i can't believe this hasn't gone
out come on what do you want mom killing
me brother
take charge mom you know how to rip into
me for two days saying i'm never gonna
grow up shut the [ __ ] cop well this is
why i never grow up mom you are the boss
start acting like one take charge don't
do this [ __ ] man take charge all the
little things mushroomed into a big
thing i'm sorry we're trying the best we
can
[Music]
that's the table that just walked out
can you find out where peter is and ask
him what the [ __ ] he's doing please yeah
peter
i don't know what i'm doing peter
peter i'm ready to give him my reins
back again
my father right now is turning over in
his grave
it's the big relaunch of the seascape
and the restaurant is at full capacity
but with the front of the house not
communicating with the kitchen way too
many people touching food in this
kitchen my apologies i'm sorry
peter is losing control
peter i need two seconds with you
[Music]
i really want you to [ __ ] shine
tonight you've got no idea do you take
control when you're not happy with
certain things get it off your [ __ ]
chest think back to the boxing ring
that's underrated asking you to be vile
no no no no no no no you're right i'm
just asking you to run yourself
gordon is 100 right here tonight i got
to prove to myself to my employees to my
mother that i'm willing to take a
challenge and be a boss you can do it
pay us for one favor of course you can
can i have a hug a hug why not here we
go let's go i don't know yeah let's do
it tonight let's go hey do it yes we got
it i'll try stand up straight okay
all right guys we're starting it up i
know what it has to get done i might
piss some people off but sorry we gotta
get it done right we are making a plan
right now okay take this off okay there
we go we make a new one right at a
critical time in the night gordon's pep
talk has finally inspired peter
i asked john baptiste to go back into
the kitchen and start our next like the
food to make the food go out faster so
we can sit the people down
just to me they take the order and give
it a new number and explain to jon
patties what it is now you can talk to
marilyn while she's here and i'll find
out from diane it's what they call
improvising good
you're gonna get your four top mountains
and get her three top here you had
gotten the bar table right yes thank you
okay here we go finally
you're on a roll marilyn you're on a
roll baby i felt like i was back when i
first opened up when the passion was
still here we were moving and grooving
finally got everything under control
out of this world
considering where the seascape was just
days ago the reopening was a success
please thank you sit down yes okay
what a nice it was only just
literally a few days ago that this place
was closed we met the chef today for the
first time to put that standard out job
well done
finally i feel peter actually took
charge so i'm really really happy we
know where to work at it to get a better
yes but for me
i know damn well customers tonight will
come back yes
you have to seriously continue running
your business yes
[Music]
as the week progressed gordon worked
with the new chef to come up with a
vibrant new menu making sure to
introduce fresh produce from the local
vendors you are the luckiest owner in
the world to have this boat in your
backyard yes i'm telling you
then to endear the restaurant back into
the community gordon created an annual
chowder cook-off that was judged by the
town mayor ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the
seascape yes
i quite like that little burning
sensation the back of my throat it's
good different the winner joe barini
welcome
[Applause]
please come back and taste it on the
menu for dinner
scott the new chef whipped the kitchen
into shape you're not doing that table
first this one right here please i'm
sorry ordering a crab cake two oysters
and maryland brought back one of
seascape's old traditions tableside
flambe
[Music]
very good
place was alive and everybody was
smiling is it lovely oh it's bright
if you've got some room don't be scared
to ask for more yes
last but not least a new respect has
been established by a mother for her son
all right mom let's start it up uh okay
we have a party of six that they call
okay so you're leaving us tonight yes
it is amazing what he did he taught me
to stand up and be the owner
love and support yes
love you man
take care thank you thank you for
everything not at all stand strong buddy
yes i will up
yes you got it one two three i got it i
feel very grateful to chef ramsay i will
never forget what the man did he put his
heart and soul into this place he did
save us
even though gordon successfully restored
the seascape to its former glory peter
accepted an offer that he couldn't
refuse and sold the restaurant
you